claude jones ou professeur de stratégie
et de management international de
l'université laval à québec jones ou
bonsoir
bonjour monsieur fillion alors tout ça
arrive en pleine période de festivités
il faut dire c'est le nouvel an chinois
quelles sont les conséquences
économiques immédiates de l'éclosion de
cette maladie tout à fait c'est mal
tombé parce que le vin sans que c'est à
dire de 20 janvier la chine et commencer
une nouvelle année lunaire
donc dans ce cas vous savez c'est une
période de festivités majeur c'est comme
noël tu entends les pays occidentaux
donc voilà il ya beaucoup de
déplacements il ya beaucoup de
rencontres il ya beaucoup de dépenses
totales boss est une période de
dépendance
vous savez c'est très difficile id ou
c'est trop tôt de faire un pilote
conséquences économiques de cette
épidémie internautes conditions fait un
parallèle 2019 l'année dernière donc tu
rends les seulement 6e jour des
festivités officielles sont coupables
vacances officielle du nouvel an chinois
dont les chinois ont dépensé en six
jours à peu près 150 milliards $ us pour
des dépenses hockey et c'est aussi une
période de voyage à parce que tenez vous
bien
l'année dernière pendant cette période
de festivités donc autour de noël en
pendant à peu près un mois c'est que
c'est un pays d'un milliard 400 millions
de personnes et en plus tous les chinois
ne voyage pas mais malgré tout les
chinois ont pré 3 milliards fois des
moyens de transport majeur donc imaginer
la consigne reste c'est énorme
la consommation représente les deux
tiers de l'économie chinoise ce que
c'est ce qu'on voit de ce côté ci est
également le taux de croissance des
ventes au détail avait diminué de moitié
lors de l'épidémie du sras en 2003 est
ce que cette fois ci ce sera plus
important qu'à l'époque du strass selon
vous je dirais que c'est c'est vraiment
trop tôt de mesurer les conséquences
parce qu'il ya sept ans immédiat c'est
sûr pour des secteurs d'un service donc
le loisir transport restauration ou
l'hôtellerie
c'est sûr que la conséquence est
désastreuse ok mais de l'autre côté
il faut pas faire à part a l'air trop
rapide avec le strass de 2012 fin 2002
et 2003 pourquoi parce que c'est vrai
que la situation pourrait changer d'un
côté par exemple moyen de transport est
beaucoup plus développée qui facilite à
je dirais transmission de se rendre
virus hockey et de l'autre côté quand
même c'est que depuis 17 ans quant au
but là le christ de strass le système de
santé public en chine
c'est pourquoi amélioré il faut
reconnaître par exemple cette fois ci
grâce des spectateurs ou des méthodes
informatiques avancées
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile de
tracer les gens qui sont venus par
exemple visiter ou un cette ville perso
je dirais tinseau virus c'est une grande
ville qui compte quand même à plus que
10 millions de personnes
oui et aussi oui savons donc d'en savoir
plus de moyens et ensuite bien sûr c'est
que vous savez à l'époque que l'économie
chinoise est beaucoup plus petit
aujourd'hui c'est tout et presque tout
plat tant que taille de l'économie
chinoise
donc exit et voilà et surtout le set
facile virus est beaucoup plus sur noye
parce que vous avez tant que le symptôme
n'est pas toujours évident quand même on
est content and contaminés par par cette
maladie donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on crée une approbation qui
pourrait sauter générés mais quelle sera
la conséquence en vous savez et c'est
pour ça se mange les chinois retourne
pour travailler et c'est pour ça que
j'en sous qu'on a décidé d'annuler
toutes les activités sportives jusqu'au
mois d'avril exactement par exemple
c'est vrai que l'autorité chinoise ont
pris des mesures draconiennes et la
nature de ce régime se permet il faut
reconnaître que dans ce cas par exemple
moi je suis un passionné des activités
sportif entre autres parce qu'elle porte
je regarde un billet aussi cib et donc à
la le china basket associés c'est vrai
que tous les activités sportifs ont été
repoussées jusqu'à avril tout dernier
donc dans ce cas bien sûr aussi les feux
les les films nos films en primeur
ils sont tous annulés donc pour éviter
que les gens se rencontrent
oui continuez
donc attention car bien sûr on peut
imaginer les conséquences
il ya conséquences économiques et aussi
bien sur les sentiments des
consommateurs chinois
cette période est absolument important
surtout il y a beaucoup de jeunes
travailleurs qui viennent de régions
rurales pour travailler en ville durant
une année c'est la seule période pour
retourner à la maison pour voir les
parents les enfants existera donc
imaginer ces mesures draconiennes au
tango tpo textes nécessaires mais
l'autre côté c'est simplement raté les
40 ans quand est ce que tu en quelle
mesure ça pourrait justement provoquer
des colères la population au sein des
populations parce que sur le site et il
ya beaucoup de rumeurs il ya beaucoup de
confusion un lot de côté exactement est
ce que ces mesures sont sont prises à
temps parce que selon certaines vous
savez c'est quinze villes en quarantaine
est-ce que c'est pas trop tard parce que
quand même il ya beaucoup de gens qui
ont aidé à quitter la ville et aux
bourrins donc ils sont à leur tour en
chine et même à l'étranger
est ce qu'avec le congé pour le nouvel
an chinois les marchés boursiers sont
fermés jusqu'à jeudi prochain et ce
qu'il faut s'attendre à une chute
boursière un effet comme cela
or je crois bien ce cas la veille de
fermeture je tiens la tanière jours au
t2 pour ce chinois
on a connu une chute et à shanghai et à
shenzhen à peu près 2 ou 3%
il faut attendre pourquoi parce que
convoyer mounaud beaucoup de secteurs
qui vont être affectés ne reste à court
terme donc bien sûr d ahmed issa sont
prudents et surtout dans le cas de chine
donc il faut attendre des transporteurs
tt votre détail ou de fabrication de
certains biens ou bien la service
loisirs vont être affectés étant que ça
ça traduit sur les pouces
je dirais en chine et même temps aussi
les pays voisins asiatiques à apprend
que l'on voit déjà tes volatilité
beaucoup plus prononcée et même des
chutes et bien sûr en convoi ok même en
europe parce que la chine temps 50 ans
mène seul un grand marché pour quelques
pays européens
donc bien sûr pas encore par exemple
produit de luxe oui dont là où va la
volatilité on voit une réaction très
négatif pour en dissiper d'éventuelles
catastrophes ou des crises qu en fait
bien
alors bien sûr on va s'y intéresser
d'abord sur l'enjeu de la santé publique
la santé des gens mais les effets
économiques également jones ou à québec
merci beaucoup
ainsi on aura nos voix